on how exactly what who's making the
calls what's being done
uh from the white house and from the
president and vice president on down
uh to lobby congress and make it happen
well it's going to require congress and
leaders in congress to move that forward
and the president is eager
to sign the george floyd act into law
eager to sign
a police reform bill into law thinks
those reforms are long
overdue there are conversations
happening on capitol hill that i will
allow them to brief you on there are
leaders who have been outspoken whether
it's senator cory booker
senator tim scott others in the house
who are engaged in discussions about
what the path could look like moving
forward
we certainly understand and know that
the initial
bill that was passed there could be
changes that's democracy in action
that's how
legislating happens and again the
president's eager to sign that bill
uh we will continue to have senior
officials engage with members of
congress on it
okay mike memoline i haven't seen i i've
not seen you in the briefing room yet so
welcome to the briefing room in the
biden harris administration i am
glad i found my way back yes um to
follow up on the issue
of guns by some measures this is at
least
the third mass shooting of this
president's young
administration he's described this as an
epidemic
gun violence in this country and we've
seen in terms of the response to covet
19
what an all of government response from
this administration looks like to
a pandemic why not the same level of
response to this ongoing issue of gun
violence than
pointing out the senior czar for
instance beyond just the efforts they're
being made on legislation
well first let me say or reiterate as
you said and the president has said
he believes gun violence is an epidemic
it's a public health crisis
it's destroying communities across the
country he's also been working
on this issue for decades and if he were
standing here and i know there's a press
conference later today and you all may
ask him about this he would tell you
that we can't give up just because it's
hard
just because the politics are perplexing
which they are given more than 80
of the public supports universal
background checks and yet the senate has
not moved forward and because bills
aren't sailing forward
um and we need to keep at it and so i
would say the way he approaches this
is one where uh he has used the levers
of his presidency
put in place already announced last week
executive action steps that the
department of justice
is going to take we will continue to
review additional options those are
steps he can take
in order to put permanent changes in
place in order to put permanent gun
safety measures in place that is we're
going to require congress acting
states can also take action we've seen
red flags
laws put in place in 19 states across
the country more states than that have
universal background checks
he also believes that working with
advocates many of whom he invited here
last week to have those discussions
encourage them
lift up their efforts is part of how we
can move things forward
i will tell you that this is a priority
to him it's a priority to the vice
president
it's a priority to susan rice who's
leading the domestic policy council
to bruce reed who is a deputy chief of
staff to ron clayne who's the chief of
staff and is from indianapolis
and this is a constant discussion and
issue around this white house so
it's not going to require a czar it is
ultimately a priority
to the president of the united states
which is the most important factor on
legislation just a few weeks ago i asked
the president
if he was going to be making phone calls
to republicans in particular
in the senate to try to advance the
background check legislation there
he said he would be willing to i know
the jobs bill has been the priority
is there more you can say about the kind
of outreach he's been doing on
background check specifically
well i don't have any calls to read out
um specifically but i can tell you that
in his conversations and he has been
talking with republicans about a range
of issues but
there are a lot of topics that certainly
come up and
you know he believes that um you know
you mentioned the third mass shooting
it's actually the third mass shooting in
indianapolis this year just to give you
all a sense uh
is also the 14th anniversary of the the
virginia tech shooting when 33 people
lost their lives
so in the president's view this is an
issue that is not
partisan it should not be political
despite the efforts of the nra over time
this is an
issue that democrats republicans
independents across the country
believe universal background checks
should happen and that certainly is the
message that he will continue to send
publicly and privately in conversations
on russia i wanted to follow up on the
announcement yesterday of at least the
intention to hold a summit with
president putin the president himself
yesterday afternoon said that he
expected or hoped
uh that that meeting would happen i
wonder though why would you announce
a summit in attention without a
commitment we still haven't heard one
from moscow as you know a high-level
meeting of this sort is often a point of
leverage
with the world leader to try to you know
bring back uh
change behavior as it were why was that
um
why are there conditions on this meeting
if there has well it was
raised in the call and so it was in the
readout of the call that the president
had made this
uh made this offer to have a discussion
and a meeting with president putin
and that call also included a discussion
in the president being clear that there
would be consequences for the actions
whether it was the hacking solar winds
or
other uh problematic behavior
by russian leadership and the president
offered that as a
to give to send the message that uh we
will have disagreement
we're not going to hold back on that but
our objective is to have a predictable
and stable relationship we can disagree
in areas where we will continue to
we're not naive about that but we also
believe
that there's an opportunity to work
together in some areas so
we are certainly hopeful that uh we will
be able to uh put together the details
on that meeting but it wasn't pre-cooked
or pre-set before the president's
discussion with president putin
and it was just uh providing transparent
information to all of you
about uh his offer to president putin if
he says no though wouldn't that indicate
some weakness on the part of the
american administration here
well i think uh the president's view is
that
russia is uh on the outside of the
global community in many respects at
this point in time
it's the g7 not the g8 uh they have
obviously we've put sanctions in place
uh in order to send a clear message that
there should be consequences for the
actions the europeans have also done
that
what the president is offering is a
bridge back and
uh so certainly he believes it's in
their interest to uh take him up on that
offer go ahead thank you jen earlier
this week you said that the u.s had
secured commitments
with the governments of mexico guatemala
and honduras to bolster
security forces at their border but
yesterday the special envoy for the
northern triangle testified
on capitol hill that there were no
agreements so
can you explain the discrepancy i'd have
to look
back at his um testimony kristen i have
it right here he said he was asked by
congressman castro
he said uh congressman caster asked him
i just want to confirm were there any
agreements reached in relation to
increasing border security in these
countries
and the special envoy said no there were
no agreements concluded with governments
regarding border security well whether
or not it was a a formal agreement which
it was not and i never conveyed that it
was
these were steps that these countries
indicated they planned to take to
increase
personnel and security to reduce the
number of migrants coming across the
border
those are steps they've taken on the
ground just to be clear are there are
these new commitments
that the biden administration has
secured or were they
already in existence we never described
it as a formal
declaration or a formal agreement but uh
additional steps that they
were taking to increase personnel at the
border and those are steps you can
confirm with those countries that they
have taken
okay go ahead i just have to get around
to everyone so i'll come back to you i
promise go ahead
if i can go back to them safety
legislation on the hill yeah we're
hearing you talk over and over again
about the president's support of the
house bills but right now it just
doesn't seem like they're
you guys have those votes in the senate
but we've heard from some republican
senators
a willingness to work on a more limited
package around
background checks so why not pitch
something a little bit more limited try
to get
something across the finish line is the
president willing to engage
on a more targeted background check bill
i would say we should
i would punt that question back to the
republicans who are not
supportive of universal background
checks or an extension of that which 80
percent of the public supports so
our question to them would be why don't
you support what the vast majority of
your own constituents support
and this is an expansion of background
checks which prevents guns getting into
the hands of
people who should not have them so
that's where i would punch you and
you're saying that the executive actions
the president took on gun safety over
initial steps you said you've used that
phrase over and over
so what's what's next give us some
preview of what other executive actions
you guys are considering because
otherwise it's just
passing the buck to capitol hill i think
it's hardly that
and again i would say the president has
been working on these issues
throughout his career for decades um he
helped get the assault weapons ban
passed he helped get background checks
passed as a part of the brady bill
he helped lead the effort to get two
dozen negative actions in place
when he was vice president and just took
actions on his own
there is a responsibility and a role for
the senate to play
there's a separation of powers here and
also he's looking forward to signing
that legislation
so i would say that advocates should
pressure
republicans in in the senate that all of
you should pressure republicans in the
senate and ask them
why they are opposing universal
background checks when the vast majority
of the american public supports it
go ahead jennifer oh thanks um on the
cyber
attacks and the sanctions on russia
yesterday
a spokesman for the kremlin says that
the u.s has been informed about what
their response responses can you share
what
russia's responses please i will let
them
share what their response is on their
own i am blissfully not a spokesperson
for the kremlin uh but
they have indicated they were going to
have a response i don't have more i can
i can react to it once we know what the
details are has white house been
informed about what their response is
going to be uh
not as of earlier this morning but i can
check with our national security team if
there are more details okay on
infrastructure is there anything that
you can update
us on about the negotiations and these
serious negotiations have happening with
the geop
on paperwork anything you can share on
infrastructure we're waiting for they've
indicated that they're working through
that so we
look forward to seriously
considering um any uh any essay
that comes our way uh but as far as i
would say there are basically two
options to pay for this job grading plan
the president believes it should be done
by having corporations pay their fair
share that's what he's proposed an
increase in the corporate tax rate
global minimum tax
uh some in congress think that uh it
should be paid for by putting the burden
on the backs of americans
we're happy to have that debate but
that's the fundamental disagreement
those are the two major options
one last thing on the american families
act on the american family yeah can you
get any guidance for us on when we'll
see that what might be in it
any update on that not quite yet but
again uh remain on track to having more
to share with you in the coming
weeks um go ahead thank you very much
um about summits uh ukraine's president
just this morning called for a summit
with
uh france germany in the us is the
president
going to sign up to that i had not heard
that from our national security team
i'll see if there's
if we have any plans or have made any
decisions about participating
it's very new um and on japan
with just less than 100 days to go to
the olympics and
even the torch relay seems to be in all
sorts of trouble um
what is the president's feeling now
about the advisability
safety etc of the u.s team going there
and
will he be going there if finland just
goes ahead i don't have any plans to
announce as it relates to travel or any
international travel
uh today i can say that we understand
the careful considerations that the
japanese government and the
international
olympic committee are weighing as they
prepare for the tokyo olympics this
summer
the government of japan has stressed
that public health remains the central
priority
as they plan to host the games uh tokyo
has assured us
uh they will keep in close contact with
washington as their plans
develop uh but i don't have any more uh
beyond that i'm sure it will be
discussed
today and you all may ask them during
the press conference later this
afternoon
okay that's just one more japan question
go ahead
um the president obviously has the
environment high on his list of
priorities
um so will he be talking to the prime
minister about the
plan to discharge uh looks like a
million tons of contaminated water from
the fukushima
plant which a lot of countries in the in
the region
and i think the u.n as well have said
it's not not a great idea
what's his position i expect that will
be discussed
i will also convey that the prime
minister has announced um
that he will join the united states in
announcing a new 20
30 target by the april 22nd leader
summit on climate
uh and japan is committed to this target
and being a part of the effort to reach
20 to
net zero targets by 2050 uh but i expect
there'll be more of a readout following
the meeting today
go ahead uh thanks jen i was wondering
if the president
actually watched the adam toledo video
and then also what his reaction was to
it
uh i have not spoken with him this
morning i expect i'll see him later this
morning i will say for
those of us who did watch that video uh
it is
uh certainly um chilling and a reminder
uh
that across the country uh there are far
too many communities
uh where there is violence that is
impacting
uh uh that that too often in this
country law enforcement uses
unnecessary force too often resulting in
the death of black and brown americans
the president again has repeatedly said
that he believes we need police reform
that's what he says he's calling for
congress to send to his desk
there's an independent investigation as
you well know and certainly we'll see
that
play itself through and then also have
the biden's been in touch with prince
harry are any members of the world
family ahead of saturday's funeral
and do they plan to send flowers or are
we or any sort of gestures of goodwill
i'm not aware of any points of contact i
will i'm happy to check with our team
and see if there's anything that will be
sent ahead of time
uh trevor i'm sorry i missed you go
ahead no um so uh
there's kind of a historic moment that's
playing out in cuba
in terms of uh castro strep and stepping
down from the communist party
um and a moving uh a changing of the
guard in terms of the castro family
um moving on into leadership do you have
any um
reaction to that and and why haven't we
seen anything
from the president as far as sanctions
are concerned
well broadly speaking um our policy as
it relates to cuba
is going to be governed by two
principles uh support for democracy and
human rights
will be at the core of our efforts
through empowering and empowering the
cuban people to determine their own
future and second our belief that
americans especially cuban americans are
the best ambassadors
for freedom and prosperity uh a cuba
policy shift
or additional steps is currently not
among the president's top
foreign policy priorities um but it is
an issue
of course we uh will remain engaged in
and focused on and
i can see if there's more of a reaction
to the change in leadership absolutely
and then just on the the japan uh visit
today
any update on uh any assistance that can
be given to japan they're very early
in terms of their vaccination effort is
that something that's going to be
discussed do you have anything to offer
them on that and then
um is there an update on on north korea
uh as well there's some indication that
they have additional
reprocessing capabilities that will
allow them to produce more
facile material for nuclear weapons sure
well first i we do expect that
president biden and the prime minister
will discuss
kovid and efforts to address and get the
pandemic under control
they've also discussed as a part of the
quad of course there's been a discussion
about
increasing cooperation and support
through kovacs
uh but we expect they will discuss that
uh and
um that will be a part of the readout
following the meeting
um as it relates to north korea as you
know there has been an ongoing review
which we're nearing
the end of that review um japan has been
consulted all along but the two leaders
meeting in person is obviously an
opportunity to discuss that in person
which will certainly be a part of the
discussion uh we
understand we what i would underscore
japan's interest in this issue
not only the nuclear program but
obviously
stability in the region so they will
discuss that and expect it'll be part of
the
readout as well uh go in the back thanks
jim um
today's meeting with the japanese prime
minister is of course the president's
first face to face yeah with a foreign
leader
given that we are still in the middle of
a pandemic can you talk about why
why you decided that it's now safe to
hold these kinds of meetings
and what kind of safety protocols will
be in place well i can assure you that
we we make these decisions very
carefully and thoughtfully and that
we ensure that there is adequate testing
social distancing
processes that are put in place to
ensure that all participants are kept
safe and that we're taking into account
uh the pandemic
there won't be a meal as an example
which would be
standard and traditional for a visit
like this um
and of course they will be uh spread out
at the press conference and also
even in their meetings an expanded
bilateral meeting and also it of course
impacts the limited number of reporters
that we will have there for the press
conference so
there are a number of steps we take it
doesn't look exactly like the
bilateral in-person meetings that many
of you have attended in the past and
you know we look forward to returning uh
to normal on many fronts but certainly
this one as well
and one more thing i know that you said
president moon of south korea
will be coming to washington and i think
you said lately yeah
um what other visits can we expect about
foreign leaders and
i know you've been asked this before but
again we can only expect the president
to start traveling abroad i'm ready too
um
you know i would say that um it should
send a strong message
about the first two visits that the
president will have in person
the leaders of japan and south korea
send a message about
how vital and important the
relationships in that region
the stability in the region security in
the region economic partnerships in the
region are
to this white house i don't have
additional
foreign leader visits to predict quite
yet of course there will certainly be
more
and in terms of the president's foreign
travel i just don't have anything yet
hopefully we'll have something more soon
understand the interest go ahead
and iran today announced that it had
enriched uranium at a 60 level does the
white house view this as a worrisome
development and also
how does it affect the president's plan
to revive the iran nuclear deal
i believe they made the announcement
earlier this week but but regardless
um as we stated earlier this week we
take seriously iran's
provocative announcement of its
intention to begin enriching uranium to
60
which the p5 plus one should be unified
in rejecting
the step uh both calls into question
around seriousness with regard
to the nuclear talks and underscores the
imperative of returning to mutual
compliance
now there are indirect talks that are
happening right now that started last
week that were ongoing through
today and well we know these talks we
expected these talks to be difficult
to be long uh we still feel that they
are a step forward and moving towards uh
you know leading with diplomacy to to
find a path forward one more on russia
the president yesterday did not mention
alexi navalny
in his remarks at all obviously the the
u.s had taken earlier action the
president had spoken earlier was there a
reason why there was the omission of an
evolve
in navalny yesterday he was announcing
steps in reaction to the other
parts of the review we had already
announced sanctions as it related to
alexey navalny
uh and so and we had previously
announced those which i know
a lot's happening so all right yeah uh
oh let me just go over get around to
everything
uh yesterday you said that president
biden remains committed
to raising the refugee cap to the higher
levels
you previewed um but advocates have been
questioning whether the delay to that
move
is based on the situation in the border
um
is it true that president biden doesn't
want to raise the refugee cap
while the situation at the border is
like it is right now
well i actually expect we'll have some
more news on this today um
so stay tuned um but i would say that it
is a factor
or which is on a part of hhs does do
refugee
uh does do management and has personnel
working on both
issues and so we have to ensure that
there is capacity and ability to
manage uh both now i will say that the
other piece that has been a factor is
that
um it took us some time to see and
evaluate
um how um how on uh
how ineffective or how uh trashed in
some ways the refugee processing system
had become
and so we had to rebuild some of those
muscles uh and put it
back in place but i expect again we'll
have more news on this
uh today and uh we'll share that with
all of you
um go in the bathroom thank you jane
another question about
uh first meeting with separate princess
sugar yeah
yesterday taiwan will be on the joint
statement
can you talk about more about taiwan why
are you going to say
be patient search wait until joint
statement or
well we've been clear um publicly and
privately about our growing concerns
about
china's aggression towards taiwan china
has taken
increasingly coercive action to undercut
democracy in taiwan and we've seen a
concerning increase in prc
military activity in the taiwan strait
which we believe is potentially
destabilizing our common position on
taiwan
with the japanese alliance alliance and
and the secretary our secretary of the
defense and secretary of
state have made uh statements to that uh
that are consistent with that over the
past weeks uh as well
to to elevate that uh but of course
we'll have again
a press conference we'll have a joint
statement and i'm sure they will address
that
following the meetings go ahead in the
back thanks jen
the u.s ambassador to the u.n to thomas
greenfield
talking to a group on wednesday said
that
white essentially said that white
supremacy is woven into
our founding documents and principles
now this statement is getting widely
criticized as essentially
parodying chinese communist party
talking points
so is the president going to remove her
from her position as
the representative before that body to
promote
united states values is the president
going to remove
an african-american woman with decades
of experience in the foreign service
who's widely respected around the world
from her position
as ambassador to the un he is not he
will he is proud to have her in that
position
he she is not only qualified uh he
believes she is exactly the right person
in that role at this moment in time i i
have not seen her comments
i will say that there's no question that
there has been a history of
institutional racism in this country and
that doesn't require the un ambassador
to confirm that
essentially the same lecture though that
the chinese delegation gave secretary
blinken in alaska
last month so does the president think
our founding documents
are racist i would say that uh i will uh
i will leave my comments to speak for it
themselves
and certainly i think most people
recognize the history of systemic racism
in our country
uh and uh she was speaking to that
uh go ahead and i promise kristen and
get back to her too go ahead a quick
question uh and then a longer one
um in terms of you said the president
have been tested for covid19 today
has that been regular or is that
specifically part of the protocols for
today's
manner the foreign today was the most
timely so we will continue to try to do
that
and then i wanted to ask you about some
new reporting uh from one of my
colleagues
she has a new piece about uh secret
facebook groups that are primarily
composed of special forces
which include some of the postings uh
very racist language
uh criticism of the government even some
q a
type conspiracy theories i wonder if you
had a reaction to the report
and also if you could give an update on
the tasking that the president had
issued for us in the intelligence
community as well as dhs
on domestic extremism yeah so the it is
a 100-day review which we are getting
close to the conclusion of and a lot of
the analysis or the review has been done
and now we're working on the policy
phase of that and i expect we'll have
more to say after that 100 david review
concludes and certainly that review is
looking at
uh areas where we see the rise of
domestic violent extremism not through a
political prism
but places where we've seen it in the
country places where we've seen it
online
and they're looking at all of those
forums um and hopefully we'll have more
to say and that we will have more to say
on that i should say
when that review concludes the reporting
from my colleague
have you seen
would the president have a reaction to
this kind of language among some of our
most highly trained special forces in
the us armed services
i would certainly point you to the
department of defense uh but i would say
that
there's no place for racism for the
projection of that
uh in government or out of government on
forums or or publicly
speaking and certainly that is of
concern uh
seeing that to to all of us and to the
president kristen did you have another
question before we go back oh i'm sorry
and we didn't get to you and i didn't
need to but we can quickly go and then
we'll go to elia
just really quick i know we've talked
about perhaps the possibility of
splitting up the infrastructure bill but
just yesterday
one of the president's allies on capitol
hill senator chris coons really loaded
the idea of splitting it between
you know just a traditional bridges
infrastructure package
and then another one with everything
else in the american jobs plan is that
something that the white house is
seriously considering i would say that
um the president's going to have a
bipartisan meeting next week and a
number of meetings next week where the
jobs plan is going to be central to that
there are a lot of proposals floating
around there one of them is from senator
coons of course is a
close ally of the president but there
are a lot of different proposals out
there so
uh he is very open to hearing different
ideas
hearing different ways to get these
these big ideas he's put forward this
historic investment to modernize our
infrastructure
create millions of jobs for the
mechanisms for that
the construction of it the pieces that
it could flow through
he's very open to what that looks like
go ahead and then we'll go to our friend
go ahead yeah thanks ben
uh we just had a quick question for
another reporter that's
uh did the assessment of the russian
bounties include whether president trump
and his senior
administration officials have been
briefed on the threat
the assessment was done by the
intelligence community to look at
available
intelligence um so it wasn't looked at
briefings or who has been briefed it was
looked at
available intelligence a lot of that
came from detainees
uh some of that uh and and hence uh we
announced it was
low to moderate confidence but uh it's
really not
done through the prism of politics or
the prism of current and past
uh uh you know uh political appointees
but done through
the intelligence available and what can
be assessed on that basis
uh okay hello uh so as we've
as we have um announced last friday
we're going to try to bring more people
into the briefing
room to ask questions and um
bring the white house perspective out to
more
uh parts of the country so aaliyah is
from india
indian country today um aaliyah chavez
um thanks for joining us and what can i
help you with
thanks for having me i'd like to follow
up on the fact sheet that was released
this morning
from the white house regarding its
investments in combating
19 in indian country the plan for
two billion dollars for third party
billing
in the indian health system shows the
significance of
medicaid and other insurance programs
we know that some states are stingy with
medicaid regulations
does this plan demonstrate the need for
tribes to be treated
like states so that they can develop
their own eligibility rules
and priorities well uh let me just give
you all sense because everybody may not
be aware of the announcement that we
made
this morning um so we um
uh let's see here um the recently passed
legislation from congress
we announced uh additional funding
additional resources that will be made
available and so
today we announced four billion dollars
from the american rescue plan
to support covet 19 response and health
care
in indian country and we will continue
to partner and we will work directly
with tribal nations in distributing
critical resources and ensuring that
funds meet the needs of indian country
so i would say that just as we are
working
with states directly we're working with
local communities we have our own
federal programs
pharmacy programs and other programs we
will work directly with indian country
to ensure that they have the resources
the funding
the vaccine supply needed in order to
get the pandemic
under control thank you so much
go ahead yes go ahead another question
about
a key campaign promise of president
biden two tribal leaders
which was to uh immediately reinstate
the white house tribal nations
conference when can we expect to learn
more about when that conference will
happen whether it would be virtually or
in person
and and to make this happen in his first
year in office
it is certainly a big priority and
obviously we've been impacted of course
by covet and the pandemic because
to have a conference like that we'd love
to do that in person and have people
meet in person
to make it that much more constructive
and productive um
it is uh so we hope to aim for late um
2021 um and we
will we will keep working toward that i
will uh say that as you know secretary
holland traveled last week to utah
and our second gentleman has also
traveled twice to indian country and
we just announced uh that secretary
holland and domestic policy adviser
susan rice will convene the first
white house council on native american
affairs meeting
at the white house as well and this is
an interagency principles level
committee so that
shows you how important this issue is
but we look forward to having
that conference that meeting hopefully
soon thank you again it was lovely to
meet you thanks for joining us
okay um i'm sorry i have to wrap up
because i have a heart out but we have a
press conference today so you can hear
from the president thank you everyone so
much have a wonderful
friday and weekend thank you
you